series of disturbance oh I found it Jane  I think you want to see this  you all right you death threaten me Thor  was so awkward what he was freaking me  out where did he come me he said it was  Thor  you're a crazy homeless person he's  pretty cut  that cloud also how could you eat an  entire box of pop-tarts and still be  this hungry  this is going on Facebook smile your  ancestors called it magic and you call  it science well I come from a place but  I wanted the same  you'll City soon enough god I hope  you're not crazy  you swear to God the lives of the  innocent I preserve the peace I swear  I will destroy their kind because  killing an entire race and die with them  these people are innocent  I have no plans to die today  our turn  you don't know but your actions were  gonna rage  you  you